sur ces images lors d'un point presse
sur le coronavirus le vice-ministre de
la santé iranien iraj archi transpirant
se frotte le front est tous à plusieurs
reprises quelques heures plus tard
l'information est confirmée il est bien
porteur du virus
je voulais vous informer que je suis
positif pour le cours aux navires us
j'ai eu de la fièvre y hier mon test
initial s'est avéré positif tard dans la
soirée
je me suis isolé dans un endroit depuis
hier soir soyez assurés que nous
vaincrons le coronavirus soyez certains
que nous le ferons j'y crois de tout mon
coeur
prenez soin de vous ce virus est un
virus démocratique
il ne fait pas de distinction entre les
riches et les pauvres ou autres
fonctionnaires et non fonctionnaires
tout le monde peut la voir lors de cette
conférence ira jarir chier le porte
parole du gouvernement iranien avait
démenti l'affirmation d'un député
selon laquelle 50 personnes auraient
perdu la vie des suites de l'épidémie
dans la ville sainte de qom
d'où le virus est partie en iran le
gouvernement promet la transparence mais
les iraniens reste inquiet j'ai vraiment
peur il n'y a pas de masque dans les
pharmacies le gouvernement devrait
distribuer des masques gratuitement aux
gens s'ils veulent le contenir
nous avons très peur le monde entier
touchées et cela se propage la
télévision d'état nous donne des
statistiques mais quand nous allons à
l'hôpital nous voyons que c'est
différent
le nombre de décès bien plus élevé alors
que le président iranien annonce mardi
que l'iran surmonterez l'épidémie un
membre du parlement vient d'annoncer sur
twitter être également infectée par le
virus
[Musique]